nous sommes en 1967 et cette année là
dans une révolution
mesdames messieurs nous avons le plaisir
de vous présenter un programme de
télévision en couleurs par le procès des
français c'est cannes 3 au mois d'avril
1967 que la deuxième chaîne déjà à la
pointe de la technologie passe pour la
première fois en france avec leurs huit
ans avant la
sonné mais bientôt badis et antenne 2
la 2 va dans les années 70 s'imposer
dans de nombreux domaines notamment la
formation avec deux petits nouveaux
feront bien voir le printemps a perdu on
n'a pas encore changé là monsieur
bonsoir
un juge est mort ce midi à marseille le
président américain ronald reagan a
décidé d'interdire à compter du 1er
février prochain des années 80 une
époque de modernisation et parfois même
pendant ce temps là la 2 la 3 se
rapproche et finissant 92 par se marier
à brest alors ces logos
depuis hier son top seul car depuis ce
matin france télévisions c'est ceux ci
trois chaînes france 2 france 3 et
france 5 et 7 5e unis désormais par les
mêmes d'enquêté équipe est à elle 3 puis
de 40 % de l'audience france france
télévisions et donc dès aujourd'hui
l'offre de programmes la plus large et
la plus diversifiée côté habillage
d'antenne dès l'aube et bandes annonces
en passant par la pub
tout est déjà changé tout sauf bien sûr
l'essentiel la vidéothèque dessous